the Joe Rogan experience god damn it I
really need to tell people what's going
on and they don't even know but I know
because I did the reading for this and I
mean this is all just a social
experiment to see how far they can push
us listen each other away from any kind
of possible power we could have to
coalesce and go wait a minute you guys
are not going to take any more of our
money for your [ __ ] travels hey [ __ ]
[ __ ] no you can't I know you it was not
in the public sphere when she said it
was in the public well who is she
Nancy Nancy Pelosi oh it was fear god
damn Nancy Oh Nancy what'd she do
Nancy's on my last nerve
was he insane up for 10 years - Nancy
are on my last nerve you've got a lot to
answer for in San Francisco and what you
have allowed on the streets there - the
homeless people it's disgusting I go up
there and I am disgusted it's crazy
right now I don't think most people know
how bad people are living in [ __ ] and
filth their children around drug addicts
dying in this [ __ ] streets of the
richest financial district on the west
coast you know where's that money going
do you I just like and then Laura Loomer
went up to two of Nancy's vineyard
trying to find her it's like if you guys
don't get yet that it don't matter who
the president is it's all a [ __ ] scam
to put public money into private pockets
and nothing else you're being robbed and
nothing else and they're both doing it
both parties both sides both up and down
it's about the American people we have
got to go to Washington you know that
movie mrs. mr. Smith I think about we
all need to be mr. Smith and all go to
Washington is like this is our
government that is our tax money and it
will be audited as Trump has promised
and as long as President Trump continues
to make the moves to keep that promise
to us I will be supportive of him
because that needs to happen the Federal
Reserve must be audited and we have to
thank President Trump for going in that
direction how much time do you spend
thinking about this stuff 18 hours a day
I can't say everyone's mad at me it
makes no sense otherwise I mean enough
to help me understand what I've done you
need a co-host you need like a like a
journal like someone's yeah yeah
someone's gonna like sit sit whatever
Dave McHenry
who's that Tiffani mix Fitz Henry I
can't remember his fits Henry he'll find
yes TIFF I want her over my co-host oh
[ __ ] what did she do she can uncover
anything okay she goes up she's like oh
here it is
oh he was arrested in 1922 when he had
this and that John Bolton why why she
gets it all all Declassified the
government song [ __ ] do you have to make
it up Freedom of Information Act the
greatest story never told the story of
this country it's phenomenal I'd like to
see somebody make a movie on it talk to
Oliver Stone he seems I have talked to
him before did you
he's so left I'm like give it a rest huh
- left give it a rest it's not about
that you're not gonna have your one
[ __ ] commie world just dumb bastards
go away
even race somebody's [ __ ] wage pay
your people decent for [ __ ] sake let's
start there he hasn't pays people decent
well I don't know that I'm just saying
if he didn't that's true you know I'm
saying now I'm just sick of people say
POC receipt I understand just how people
get their their [ __ ] money back that
belongs to them like public money that's
for roads streets hospitals
schools okay public money when they give
input to private contractors to go to
you know where they go uh you know move
guns and [ __ ] all around the world that
means like Eisenhower said that's one
less high school for the kids come on
we're going to be the kind of a country
that leads the world we cannot we're not
we cannot be imperialist one-world
fascist
we can't do it won't work we have to do
something else so we can't be one world
fascist you mean like one world
government you know yeah leave people to
[ __ ] alone leave the tribal people in
the Middle East to live where they live
forever [ __ ] you know you know and if
you can't then separate them separate oh
yeah if they can't live together then
don't force them to live like what
people you're talking about with the
Palestinians and the Israelis like that
kind of deal well in Israel the Arab
population is very well integrated so I
don't mean Israel but out of Israel
they're not very well integrated you
know because they just get their money
from [ __ ] propaganda peddled by the
left but the people on the ground are
what I'm saying the people on the ground
are the ones that matter to me and if
you can live together then live together
that's great and if you can't then don't
nobody can force you to live with people
who want you dead
what is that that's our it's are you
[ __ ] me
I'm not gonna live with people that want
you dead I'm not not sure what you're
referring to
I'm referring to the entire world the
whole world the entire [ __ ] world led
by you know bad ideas man that haven't
worked this far it's gonna have to be
something new that actually works for
the people in the world not just the
people at the top like in the world of
course I loved him but when I ran for
president
I had my solutions or solution well I
have to tell you Joe when I was a little
girl
I made a promise to myself I guess or
and the cosmos and God and everything
that I was never I was not ever gonna I
was gonna keep trying to know no matter
what I was gonna keep trying to know and
know something new know something new
and different like what how to create a
world where something like Auschwitz
doesn't exist and even the thought of it
doesn't exist but you really can't cuz I
think when you read about Western
society and all of that you're like
maybe that was it you know that's where
it leads well it seems like throughout
history there's been evil governments
there's been certain evil organizations
that have done horrific things yeah like
way back to as far as we know from Rome
to the Inquisition to the Mongols - yeah
you know I mean there's been horrific
things done by human beings and one of
the things about knowing about things
like Auschwitz is it lets us know that
even though things in this country right
now are relatively great in comparison
to the rest of the world relatively
great comparison to some parts of the
world that are war-torn and terrible
right now it could go bad it could go
bad because that's what humans are
capable of humans are capable when
they're led by the wrong ideology when
they're that their cult minded when
they're all in there they can do some
terrible awful things and we need to
know that and it's one of the things
about having something like Auschwitz in
our history that we we know that that's
possible
[Applause]